today's episode to answer the internet
featuring business tea is brought to you
by Roman in the olden days guys would do
anything to try to last longer in bed
think about hypothetical questions with
their grandma or who would win in a
fight a shark versus a polar bear not
anymore thanks to Roman swipes with just
one easy swipe you're gonna last longer
in bed and you and your partner are both
gonna be happy go to get Roman comm
slash bar stool and get yourself a pack
for 5 bucks is this the game is this the
game yeah did you guys make this yeah oh
cool
hello hello bar stool fans I'm Paul
Bissonnette and I'm here to answer the
Internet I've seen this before and I'm
sure you're expecting wacky answers so I
smoked a little bit before you are so
let's go could LeBron beat any NHL
player in a fight like just one guy on
skates I mean he could be some of the
guys up there's little skill guys I'd
imagine Johnny Gaudreau is not gonna
beat up LeBron James although the
skating aspect may play a little bit of
a factor but even like even if he did
have LeBron on the ground he can't even
he can't hurt him enough with his muffin
punches so yes there are but not many so
and I don't like LeBron James I'm just
being honest about these answers would
you rather have your mom send you a nude
or have her send all your friends a nude
oh yeah I know I mean I think I think
I'd rather take the brunt of the the
mental damage than all my buddies and
and then not have the dent not to them
oh my god jesus crazy dial it in biz I
wouldn't want them to have that as
mental warfare moving forward in case we
got in a chirp match and then it's
always gonna end with hey man I've seen
your mom naked so I mean I think we can
all agree on that I would say 99% of you
out there would agree with me and then
the other other 1% is clinically insane
would you rather better Reginald you
there might have been a little hash in
that weed house or [ __ ] would you
rather bang a bunch of models but nobody
knows or not actually [ __ ] them but have
everyone think you know I'd rather [ __ ]
them I'm a dog I don't care I mean I
guess I'm a little nauseous because I
talk about it but I think it's you know
sex is just funny and I don't I don't
put it on a pedestal like others if you
came across a glory hole would you put
your dick in it I mean is the assumption
that the other side is a [ __ ] oh okay
sorry I thought it was a Percy could be
a wood chipper well then know that what
you don't know I'm saying okay well then
of course not I'm not running the risk I
mean I mean depends if it's been a slow
month you depending on the day depending
if it depending on this if the cialis is
wore off from the last time they've
taken it there's a lot I guess you know
what maybe I would rather jump my deck
the glory all would you rather ate [ __ ]
yourself every time you come be get a
boner every time you talk to a dude I
would I would say I would get rather get
a boner every time I talk to a dude I
mean I mean you're probably gonna have
to have the conversation like hey no
like it's your it's not what you think
it is but then you know you just got to
be polite about it might get a little
exhausting because I know I wouldn't
want to [ __ ] myself every time I came
that's [ __ ] brutal hey that's not
even close
like I was even I had to explain the B
side of it and I and I read back on the
first one and I'm like no it's
ridiculous of course I'm not taking that
are there sacred days you would refuse
to masturbate funerals tragedies
religious holidays um I mean I don't you
have to be a little bit on the dark side
if it's like the day of a funeral and
you're in you're thinking I got a rub
one out before I get out of here I I
mean I I probably wouldn't just because
if if I'm going to a funeral it's
because I know I'm gonna be sad that I'm
gonna lose I lost that person so no if
there's I'm not gonna be thinking any
type of sexual thoughts that morning now
saying this I would never masturbate on
a game day
No if I was playing in the game I would
not masturbate so most game days I was a
student [ __ ]
half the amount of games I was
passionate because I would be a healthy
scratch if you were in an open field of
the lumen baseball bat how many 10
year-olds with bike helmets could you
take down before they got you got you I
don't know man ten years old I'm gonna
eventually you're gonna tire out we're
talking they have unlimited I'm
picturing it I'm like I'm like I'd say a
hundred yeah I'm gonna get angry and I'm
gonna know what's coming to an end here
I'm gonna go down this way and no pun
intended would you rather get caught
masturbating or [ __ ] your pants in
public Oh
[ __ ] my pants for sure like if
you're not sure being imperfect you're
you're like on the sexual predator list
that's like once again this one's a
non-negotiable and I've [ __ ] myself I've
shipped myself twice in public once when
I was younger I was I was riding my
bicycle to my paper oh because I'd it
was like seniority the people who live
closest to you who'd had paper outs the
longest got to do the close routes so I
didn't [ __ ] drive my bike Wow one
morning I you know I'm driving on the
road just going with the full stack of
newspapers I lean over to take a fart
and like explosion like the wet one
right and like I've already driven my
bike are not giving a mile and a half so
I'm like what I'm not gonna go back and
so I did the whole route with [ __ ]
[ __ ] in my drawers and the stupidest
[ __ ] part about it I was still fairly
young and when I got home instead of
just throwing the underwear in the
[ __ ] garbage I put them at the bottom
of the laundry bag
and like that later that day like when I
got home from school my mom was like did
you throw these in the laundry like you
look I'm not gonna wash these I'm gonna
throw them away whether these are done
we're gonna retire these so I'm so sorry
about that mom like the common sense
hadn't kicked in by at that point and
then the other time I did it was
recently and we actually told the story
outside where I was in an airport and
you know just [ __ ] lie the fart go
and real quick once again like just you
know when you paint the inside of your
ass cheeks and it sucked because I
brand-new Lululemon underwear on and I
told the story on the podcast and sure
[ __ ] um Scotty up shawls friend who
works for Lululemon said hey let biz
know we can bring him in in Vancouver
next time he's here so the next time I
was in Vancouver they showed me around
they showed me how they make things and
how crazy the facility was and they gave
me like twenty five twenty five hundred
three thousand dollars worth of free
stuff including like ten new pairs of
underwear so [ __ ] my pants at the
airport was a blessing in disguise and I
don't care I mean whatever I'm sure
everybody I mean there was a video
recently some lady at the grocery Mart
and she just like run around the corner
and like just like yeah it's just like
that's excessive but I mean what are you
gonna do like that person had to [ __ ]
and they panicked in that moment right
no one no one who's [ __ ] in public
should be shunned because like that
could be us yeah that was there there
one moment where I probably would have
just went against the aisle and and you
know you could put your arm up on the
beef jerky rack and you you just let it
run down your leg to me you know I don't
think I'd go to the middle of the aisle
and be like I thought you were out in
the open there and get to the sidelines
like stop the clock how far are you
willing to drive for sex I'm not really
much anymore than I'm older I mean I've
I've yeah i'vei've yeah I've driven some
distance to [ __ ] for sure I mean I'd
like altered routes on the way home from
cross-country trips to have sex
you know as this I do like like save the
earth like you're just burning fuel to
get it you're going more none off like
come on unless that's like the booty is
that good I ain't I ain't really
traveling Oh would you rather have your
internet history made public or sex tape
that goes viral now I don't I don't
Google anything that's like bad like I'm
not a weirdo like that so I I would have
no problem anyone seen my Google search
entry because if they ask me about
something I'd say oh this is why I went
to go look at that that's weird
and if and I know that it's not for a
crazy reason because I'm not crazy now
on the other side things a sex tape that
goes viral
well I wouldn't if people thought that I
was the one who made it public to like
try to like benefit financially from it
no I wouldn't want it but if it
organically got out there I mean now I
know I'm gonna be able to capitalize off
it and I wasn't a part of doing that
where well I mean capitalize off it if I
[ __ ] put on a good performance I mean
it wouldn't I wouldn't want to be like a
couple pumps and dump right I want to be
like I want to be picking her up and
putting on a show so then like more
chicks want to [ __ ] me next question
would you rather have a 10-inch dick
with no balls or a 4-inch dick with
balls no I'd rather have a 10-inch dick
no balls I mean that I mean I'm assuming
that means no kids I'm on the fence on
whether I want to have it or not
anyway ball I I get I'd like to have
another three inches in wrists know how
many kids would you rather all [ __ ] it's
it's a would you rather sit on a cake
and eat a dick sit on a dick and eat a
cake
I mean [ __ ] I'm just trying to think of
what I want to dick of my mouth or my
ass I'd probably say the mouth I thought
I'd suck a dick rather than get [ __ ]
in the ass that's a--that's an easier
way to ask ask that question but with
this cake the cake has nothing to do
with the question yeah you put the cake
in there to soften it up the chicken
cake man
just give it to me straight I'd rather
suck a dick all right
you could tell the Energy's going down
I've given you guys a lot I've given you
my [ __ ] all and this is gonna be my
last one I'm gonna go out swinging if
you had to move it to a different place
on the body where would you put the
vagina now wow what a great question I
mean the [ __ ] cuz I gots like pretty
much the same thing anyway I just [ __ ]
beat this answer I [ __ ] pulp I win if
there's any way to win this game
I just [ __ ] want it oh sorry I try to
be cool and throat
you